welcome to this video again josei sunday
with the one be three remarkable
persistence I wonder is that something
about d5 just playing the open yeah
maybe I wonder about Bishop b5 and moves
like that him but how would you play it
with colors reversed what would I do
them against this maybe just develop
with Bishop e2 at Bishop e7 in this case
yeah they play Bishop d6 am and I'll
know I remember now that's not so nice
here but ok still should be fairly solid
this position just centralizing just
centralizing here
after the clock Knight c4 maybe I can
play this double fianchetto
so let's see what what can I do here
with black nem any ambitious and your
bishops tries and I do something on the
Kings side I'm playing awaiting more
first I'm not quite sure okay he's doing
something here what prevent be five for
the moment
hm
yeah this is some a position where it's
not clear to me what kind of an active
plan I maybe can pursue I mean it looks
well centralized and everything but
where exactly is my Play no maybe i can
i can at least them irritate him here
this wasn't possible before of course
because of the night the night discovery
and now he's sir doing this interesting
hmm isn't there some some technical idea
here I mean it looks it looks like there
could be something
yeah I left night F for this this kind
of idea I'm attracted to but he can he
can just take c6 and there is no no
point to it ok so I just played some
normal moves after after those um I'm
probably slightly worse as the sea porn
disobedience but it shouldn't be
anything terribly frightening unless my
queen is trapped um where do I go there
yo Queen g6 not exactly ideal about okay
Queen g fiber can I can play there is
this intermediate mate on g2
actually but we had what he did them I
now can take on d4 and give him the
isolated pawn as he needs to protect the
the maitreya first maybe night here yeah
come on I must be quick anyway
take take it I can take it also not
probably not not totally convincing all
right but this can get very very tricky
I can at least take care take on g2
because of 92 okay let's not hesitate
too long Luke c7 rookie warning this
also time morning this is some good news
unless maybe you can no I don't think so
I thought briefly can maybe I can play
night III actually okay but I can first
take Here I am
maybe maybe I'm threatening night III he
actually is this this is an additional
idea at least a 93 95 95 I could have
done that anyway maybe Jegs but this is
also just just just just winning a piece
right
all rights still a bit a bit problematic
as the pieces are not very well
coordinated at the moment
check I'm returning some material here
to make it easier to play rook takes up
a file with two extra pawns
check-check
count three pawns check check check
check check check check check check
check white forfeits on time ooh yeah
hostile i'm a bit tricky even with the
material upper or with the the pawns
yeah he played this the strange move
from Bishop e2 which which really am
yeah was just nice for me because of
this made threat with Queen g5 I think
from a structural point of view white is
just somewhat better here I thought that
maybe a move like this should be okay
like this keeping the default and maybe
see several is a weakness it's it's
probably not a terrible position for
black but white is certainly a bit more
comfortable yet after this some I'm just
I'm just somewhat more more comfortable
with the better structure and he okay
rook III was working I was I suspected
that but i didn't i didn't see
actly rock III is working so let's I
let's check this check yeah I wasn't I
wasn't even sure about this but I Queen
h3 of course okay so this one chat here
here what is the point after this this
one yeah neither force is quite
something yeah night age 39 f to energy
form this is the the real problem this
attack is too strong yeah okay i didn't
sr 0 ki three but i thought okay this
leading to a good good position as well
but it wasn't so convincing of course
yeah after that I had to what I played
in the game and Thiago p1 is winning
with exactly how unplayed okay there's
something better here no no I think I
did a good job here it's prom to prom me
there was something better than
returning the piece but it did it was
the easiest to play and should be and
should be a fairly fairly simple window
okay thanks for watching